good morning Hank it's Tuesday in a
stirring turn of events I have found
myself in an airport specifically the
Birmingham Alabama Airport a great
Airport in almost every respect I mean
there's a playground it's spacious the
food is good there's free Wi-Fi there's
just one fatal flaw music that I have
not chosen to listen to pipes out of
every one of these and there are
thousands of them I've been in
Birmingham for just over 12 hours I met
Looking for Alaska director Becca Thomas
and took her to my old high school she's
working it was really fun went to campus
in the middle of the night and I took
her to the place where I used to smoke
cigarettes don't smoke and there was
graffiti there that said the best is yet
to come which is one of the very few
things in life I believe to be
fundamentally and incontrovertibly true
but now I have to leave Birmingham to go
to New York City I don't exactly know
why I'm going to New York City probably
to do press stuff but anyway I know that
I'm going and then my tomorrow which
will be your today I will be in
Indianapolis for the start of the Paper
Towns tour and I'll get to hang out with
NAT and Cara and Akilah Hughes and lots
of nerdfighters and then we will go on
to Columbus and then Dallas there is
info about all the events which are free
in the doobly-doo oh god I hate the song
so much I have to find a way out of it
hold on there's no way out Hank the
Sounders everywhere do you know the song
circle in the sand that's the song into
everywhere it's literally everywhere
look at all of these speakers it's
killing me okay I think I found the
place in the Birmingham Airport that is
literally as far away from the speakers
you can be which is still not very far
what was I supposed to talk about today
the best is yet to come the tour the
movie Paper Towns opens July 24th there
was something Oh Brazil the movie
already came out in Brazil it had an
amazing opening weekend thank you
Brazilian nerdfighters I'm glad that
people seem to have liked the movie the
early reviews are great which is a huge
relief to me in other news Hank as you
might be able to tell I am exhausted I
mean in the old-fashioned sense the word
like I feel that I have been drained out
like I realized these are the first
world yes to first world problems but
I'm not very good at interviews and also
I miss my family a lot like I just miss
being home like for instance when I'm at
home ah I don't have to listen to this
song and yeah the last month or so has
been really exhausting and there's still
two weeks to go I mentioned this mostly
Hank because nerdfighters seem to have
noticed it like more and more in
comments they're like you seem tired
don't don't worry if you need to take a
break and I really appreciate that
partly because frankly no one else in my
professional life is telling me that but
I'm not gonna take a break I'm not going
to take a break from the movie stuff
because it's almost over and I don't
have any like contractual obligations to
promote the movie or anything I just
really like it and I'm very
grateful to the people who made it and I
want to thank them and this is the way
and I don't want to take a break from
from this because honestly this is the
thing that makes me feel not exhausted
this is the thing that instead of
draining me fills me up because you know
for a long time in my life I would get
to a point where I would get overwhelmed
and exhausted and then I would fall into
this spiral where I would do less and
less and less and then eventually I'd be
doing nothing but I would still feel
overwhelmed and exhausted because the
thing is I didn't just stop doing the
things that drained me I also stopped
doing everything else I stopped
functioning completely so even if I do
have to vlog over a soundtrack not of my
choosing and even if the videos aren't
that good and I'm sorry if this one
isn't I'm gonna just keep swimming
because nerdfighteria is in a very real
sense a big part of what keeps me going
so nerdfighters thank you for worrying
about me but I'm okay I promise and I am
excited about the tour because I get to
meet some of you instead of just
answering the same eight questions from
press outlets over and over Hank I'm
gonna get on a plane now this is a weird
video I'll see you on Friday
old school brother's confessional
video